negli episodi precedenti ero lì il
giorno in cui la forza degli uomini 20
minuti nelle gambe
ho visto qualcosa che si muove tra
arriva con punto ragazzi dove la
doppietta finiti surimi dice che a los
angeles c'è un festival chiamato
coachella e mi chiede se voglio andare
con lui a cascella
savigi originals dopo aver passato una
settimana le hawaii riprendiamo l'aereo
torniamo a los angeles per noleggiare la
macchina che ci porterà al coachella
sono atterrata a los angeles siamo qua
per prendere la macchina e poi andremo a
prendere sul ricche in questo momento si
trova a santa monica e indovinate un po
eh si la macchina mia preferita ma mi
spiace ma stavolta non è questa ho
deciso di fare un piccolo cengio che su
questo già da alcol cella si va da veri
americani
star
madonna ma conte altra sta macchina
porca vacca sono in after completo
infatti c'è un problema perché stasera
andiamo al coachella finisce tardi
infatti sondando scroccare l'hotel di
suri per dormire gli ho detto già su
ritmi dormì perché sennò è finita
siamo in corso como perché ho sbagliato
parcheggio
non volevo speri adatti la macchina ma
tra l'altro spoiler atene ti piace la
vita ci sta mica lo so perché ci servirà
però la cella con questa riportiamo
ho aperto aperto schizzato molon
quindi l'ho preso sono curioso di queste
settimane e passeremo insieme anch'io si
no allora blog questa parte perché fa
troppo ridere questa è la salita della
prima disse in gta 5 ricordo eccetera
ricordo quasi scritto uscita ma vede
chiodi per terra possa passare da sono
detto
adesso dell'hotel e allora eccolo qui
pensavo fosse più nuovo bello bello
bello però su tutti sui pannelli vende
sims stanno costruendo adesso grado
perché giorgio è dura la differenza di
black simon e con youtube per chi non lo
fa non li spenda non si spendono i soldi
si tengono in banca poi si muore ricchi
checker hotel false ragazzi la
differenza tra me e
ho anche perso capire di preferire e ce
la fanno bellissimo che non dovrà capire
la porta bello viaggiare in due minchia
non faccio niente ma tutto salvo chi mi
chiama cucina cioè che pago finito io
adesso fare un cazzo madonna ma è
bellissima ma noi facciamo il salto
contemporanea
adesso non facciamo il suo coach e la
informiamo per tre giorni papera che mi
sono fatto se due ore di sonno e adesso
tipo la cella public by così via in
questi tool si tratta che parto che poi
si indirizzano i capelli te non hai
cancella time è il momento di divertirsi
vediamo che succede classe mai su cui
non ho messo una cintura
a zero ore 18 saranno fa vj e dj
non so perché comincia adesso la parte
del blog del coachella vero e proprio vi
avviso già che saremo un po su di giri
assurdi non abbiamo preso niente siamo
così di nostro siamo in coda per
arrivare al coachella significati la
crema solare siamo morti cioè lo
scaldacollo non sono pazzo con un caldo
bestia ma almeno non biscotto gli dice
[Musica]
siamo ribatti
e non so quanto rimane lei però
[Musica]
tutto bellissimo e tra l'altro o c'e un
attacco un ufo
oppure quali sono palloncini in aria
tantissimi tra l'altro è bellissimo ho
perso surian a coleen
tutto ok madonna ragazzi quanta
ignoranza che c'è
[Musica]
no
gli azzurri al power
[Musica]
ma chi è questa
o
io
ho
cambiato
[Musica]
tutti felicissimi guarda tutti felici
cos'è la felicità
parla gesù ricche solo farla chissà cosa
cazzo
iniziali
[Musica]
troppi grassi scupoli cognitivo le
lezioni di volo
[Musica]
bravo
formativa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
proprio in cantina
[Applauso]
[Musica]
enrico
salvo
[Musica]
tappa
colmo numero otto cani
[Musica]
roma
ha detto letta
abbiamo trovato quello per cui siamo qua
c'è la pizza margherita napoletana
questa è scritto lo schizzo lì
[Musica]
barabara la gente pensava per limonare
tutti bravissimi giovani sporchi però se
volete ci sono ragazzi questo sono stage
al microscopio
[Musica]
ecco dove gli analizzano i tamponi il
laboratorio
[Musica]
salvo quindi tutta terra guidi tutta
terra lo questa
[Musica]
ragazzi col cielo è finito
ricordatevi che guido io e quindi tutte
queste persone ogni singola persona
vedete dovrà uscire dal parcheggio
compreso il sottoscritto parla bisogno
di acqua
nel prossimo episodio siamo a times
square che figo stiamo per mangiare un
sushi epocale a quanto pare no aiutami a
vita eccolo qua ci arrestano 6 contro
costa sta roba
io non sto scherzando tu li conosci mio
blog non
parla gesù
parla